[Music]  you don't need to be bulletproof to be a  superhero black women have always had  superpowers turning pain into progress  I'm doesn't need a hero it means a queen  you're a comb I want to bring miracles  to Harlem all this could be yours I can  be the mother you always wanted me to be  dance that's where our money really  comes from it's time to let the ghosts  of the past uh I almost burn our feet  smell of flesh ugly money the bees on  your game with Jessica's everything that  belongs man should be my  Bushmaster will scorch columns to get to  her  hi-oh we can only handle one bevel at a  time I've done clean I've ever loved  [Music]  you can't be trusted  okay just do not dirty work for us  ese  my dark chocolate Boy Scout of course  you're going to save me she won't stop  ready or not  walk me out there  because without me god help Harlan  God help us all here I come  [Music]